[موسيقى]
صف رابع ابتدائي يعني اتذكر المدرسه طلبت
منه اننا نرسم قارب
اختارتني انا عشان ارسم قارب على السبوره
فرسمت بشكل جميل يعني فاستغربوا يعني فمن
من يوم ما حسيت ان انا عندي حب شغف للرسم
فبقيت بالمدرسه دائما يعني بالنسبه
لطلاب المدرسه او المدرسات
الصف او فنانه المدرسه يعني
[موسيقى]
لوحاتي اغلبها عن عن المراه عن
التراث عن الصوفيه ايضا
هي كل فتره
تدخل في مرحله مختلفه او مواضيع مختلفه في
اللوحات
[موسيقى]
يمكن بالبدايه ما كانوا يفهمون الفن بشكل
واضح وكذا
كده كده التحديات يمكن كانت شوي المجتمع
ما يتقبل الفن
ايش بيسوي لك هذا الفن وايش المردود لا
المفروض تكوني في البيت او انه تكوني يعني
موظفه او يعني ما تنشغلين يعني ما ياخذك
الفن بس اللي حلو انه انا تربيت في اسره
تحب الفن دائما
يا حياتي دور في انه يشجعني سواء والدي
اخويا اخواني يعني
ابو اولادي ابني الان يعني
ولاء اني دائما كان في تشجيع من قبل الرجل
والمراه ايضا خواتي امي يعني
صديقاتي دائما يقولوا لي يعني استمري في
هذا المجال انت هذا مجالك
[موسيقى]
لما خلصت كل المعارض
يعني مرحله
مرحله اني انا خلاص الان صار الوقت اللي
يكون لي رواق خاص فيني لانه كانت صارت في
طلبات كثيره على على لوحاتي من الخليج من
من العالم يعني من الاجانب يعني كثير
يحبون لوحاتي وصار في اقتناء بس ما في
مكان اني انهم يشوفون هذه اللوحات غير
الاستديو انا كان عندي استوديو الاستوديو
غير يعني ما عندي يعني لوحات معروضه بشكل
يعني تعرفين بالمخزن يعني ما مخطوطه بشكل
واضح انها تعرض بشكل جيد
وايضا صعب انك كل حد يجي عندي الاستوديو
لان الاستديو خاص فيني ومرسمي يعني فهنا
جاي يعني قلت ليش ما اسوي حلمي ومنها ايضا
الناس يكون يعني ملجا للسياح انا ودي مثلا
لوحاتي تعرف في اهم المتاحف
المومه
اهم الجاليريز في العالم يعني
في عليها اقبال من الزوار وكذا يمكن ايضا
يهمني ان الرواق رواق قال من شهر اكثر في
العالم
[موسيقى]